sieben tage lang hat einen astronomie
team den himmel nach planet 9 untersucht
und zwar genau den bereich in dem sich
der planet befinden müsste in den daten
der observation müsste der planet jetzt
enthalten sein es könnte also
tatsächlich bereits in den nächsten
wochen eine erfolgsmeldung geben alle
infos dazu jetzt hier im blick zum
science fiction nur hier gibt es täglich
faszinierend des seins videos abonniert
den kanal wird dann verpasst ihr nichts
herzlich willkommen die schlinge zieht
sich zu um den planeten oder planet iks
den unbekannten risiken planeten in
unserem sonnensystem
er soll sehr weit draußen um die sonne
kreisen aber deutlich größer sein als
die erde man vermutet dass es sich dabei
wohl um einen gesteinsplaneten handelt
und dass er wohl den vierfachen
durchmesser der erde hat und maximal
zehn mal so groß ist wie unser
heimatplanet der muss sich nach ansicht
vieler forschungsteams wohl am äußersten
rand des sonnensystems versteckt halten
gemeinsame bahn abweichungen
verschiedene objekte in dieser region
lassen darauf schliessen und genau diese
planabweichungen also diese beule in
deren umlaufbahn haben den bereich wo
sich der mega planet verstecken könnte
eingegrenzt konkret geht es um rund 20
größere objekte im kupfergürtel ein
gebiet außerhalb der neptun bahn deren
umlaufbahn um die sonne seltsam
verändert sind und all diese
auffälligkeiten weisen auf einen ort hin
oder ein bereich wo sich planeten
befinden müsste weswegen man planet 9
bis heute trotz intensiver suche noch
nicht beobachten konnte liegt wohl an
seiner enormen distanz zur sonne
amerikanische wissenschaftler vom
institute of technology california
hatten berechnet dass die bahn von
plavix dem planeten zu dem zeitpunkt
seiner dichtesten erdnähe wohl noch
immer 700 mal weiter an der sonne vorbei
führt als die erde in einem tweet sagt
professor mike brown jetzt wir konnten
viele nacht eine unmenge an daten
gewinnen ich habe das gefühl dass wenn
wir damit 9 mit dem subaru teleskop
finden werden der sich innerhalb die
da das verbirgt die chancen stehen also
nicht schlecht für die baldige
entdeckung des planeten und im februar
wird die suche noch mal aufgenommen und
dann soll in den daten noch mal
verschärft geforscht werden dann sollen
noch ausgereiftere algorithmen nach dem
planeten suchen wenn er bis dahin noch
nicht entdeckt worden sein sollte das
problem ist dass der planet durch das
licht der sterne hinter ihm
überstrahlt werden könnte deshalb hat
das astronomie team den himmel mehrfach
abgesucht um dieses risiko zu minimieren
braun hält es jetzt für 80
wahrscheinlich planet 9 in den daten zu
finden wenn er denn existieren sollte
aber da sind sich eigentlich astronomen
und astronom weltweit einig zu
verräterisch sind die bahn abweichungen
der beobachteten objekte mehr zu planen
oder es gibt es hier einfach
draufklicken gibt es planet ist wirklich
bei doktor watson der wieder fleißig
videos produziert also unbedingt
abonnieren das geht hier einfach
draufklicken und ansonsten würde ich mal
sagen bis dann bleib dran